Apple stunned investors with a rare
warning that revenue from its
first-quarter which includes holiday
sales will not meet expectations in part
the company blames slower iPhone sales
in China the downbeat forecast from the
tech giant is helping drag Wall Street
futures lower CEO Tim Cook said Apple
expects about 84 billion dollars in
revenue for the quarter that's actually
down from a previous forecast of 89 to
93 billion dollars Cook said a weaker
Chinese economy and trade tensions with
the US are hurting Apple it's clear that
the economy began to slow there for the
second half and what I believe to be the
case is the trade tensions between the
United States and China put additional
pressure on their economy Cook said
Apple plans to make it easier to trade
in phones and will improve financing
plans to help drive sales CBS News
business analyst Jill Schlesinger is
here good morning morning this is
remarkable what Apple has done what is
it say about our global economy well it
definitely says the Chinese economy is
slowing down
it may not be precipitous we might have
seen six and a half percent growth in
2018 those are the official figures out
of China some dispute that this year
we're looking at maybe six point two six
point three percent that seems like a
teeny tiny differentials spread off over
one point four billion people it's a lot
and that Chinese economy was slowing
down already
as before the trade tension started
bubbling up but we see the effect of
this exports down dramatically retail
sales in China down by the weakest
amount we saw the weakest reading in 15
years so things are slowing in China
that's the second largest economy in the
world it obviously impacts everyone and
obviously other companies now are going
to be playing close attention to their
revenue forecasts in China as well it's
not just Apple but you've got auto
industry and you've got the other tech
stocks too and we not only that we
definitely see it in the auto industry
but look at some of the high-end luxury
retailers that are really on neuron edge
about this we saw Tiffany come out with
a warning at their last results LVMH
also very much concerned why because the
Chinese were set to become the the
second largest consumers of luxury goods
supposedly over the next course of five
to ten years maybe 45 percent of luxury
goods being purchased by Chinese if
their economy is we can clearly they're
not going out and buying and slickly can
we directly link this to president
Trump's trade war I don't think you can
directly link it I think the trade war
has exacerbated a slowdown that was
already in effect in 2018 will continue
this year we'll keep an eye on it and
makes more likely China will strike a
deal I don't know what do I know
[Laughter]
interesting continued but really
interesting thank you and we are in that
90 day freeze as well on the trade war
so we'll see how negotiations go exactly
well thank you